even coming to you in five four three
two hello my age three warriors we're no
longer a nation or super trooper
troopers we are warriors runaway on a
war against the world we're here to be
funny in the name of war h3 warriors
thank you to MIT Mobile expressvpn and
me undies and kaptara
for becoming h3 warriors like you
they're like we're not warrior we're
just brand we're brands they're here to
be safe guys
before we begin the show h3 h3 shop comm
we're switching fulfillment services and
we need to sell everything that's on
there otherwise we basically need to
basically throw it out it's all 70% off
everything must like literally the
prices are repaired and we paid for it
you cannot find [ __ ] for this cheap
seven dollars from $27 to $8 seven
dollars I'm just I'm telling you the mud
lot of dollars it's it's ridiculous just
please go buy everything there's not
that much but please just buy everything
it's so cheap just help us please
because well basically or don't well
throw it out because we're basically not
making money from selling it to you
anyway so do it that of what you will
thank you guys
guys now that we have gotten past all of
that I bring you a terrific way to start
your Friday yeah news anchors trying to
relate to young people
I am always animus Lee fascinated by by
news anchors you know they really they
got swag it's just it's an interesting
job to begin with because you're you
literally are just reading a
teleprompter like there's no personality
there's no you're just like a human
vessel for conveying words on the screen
it actually it looks like a really toxic
environment to me usually whenever I
watch this guy's like it's very like
phony like what music roles in the life
yeah good night everybody no but that's
why anchorman was so such a fantastic
don't because you know it is like that
like when it goes to mute and they're
like Susan Susan you're such a [ __ ] or
whatever but here you go what do you
guys think of this breakfast goals
say bye Felicia to that testing stress
weather's gonna be turned right Chris
yeah little weather gonna be lit during
testing weak tornadoes big chances
success you've got this kids Steve how
about that traffic are we look at okay
no traffic problems around any TPS
schools to keep you from taking those
tests so get a good night's sleep do
your best in fact be extra extra we here
at WTOL RV proud of you alright what do
you think about that is that are all the
students getting motivated from that or
what they're all gonna fail I'm not
going to school today
absolutely curse that's basically like
the Columbine kid being like don't go to
school today
nope dark but it's kind of the same home
in isn't it the weather is today the
first time he says heat yeah these guys
a rule these guys rule can you play it
yeah of course CPS students it is
testing week and it's time to slay all
day you kids really talk like this
though like oh are you sure because you
know I watched Logan Paul and he talks
like this but I'm like oh he's just a
he's like a weirdo but I think that the
kids are actually talking like this yeah
I mean Logan Paul's a hero dude
everybody needs a hero everybody needs a
hero who's out you're referencing that
slick
very culturally literate Dan my
observation turn so I just want to get
everyone super excited turned up and
littie he'd they forgot to say littie I
heard a Liddy in there they said let did
they also say let see big difference so
guys I just wanted to say I hope that
your Friday is pretty and you're having
a litter
I don't know what they're saying I don't
know what else there is
you're so basic he's an extra extra yeah
somebody said that to me recently I was
like sorry X Jax or what
I'm out all about it yeah I'm out I'm
I'm officially out of a had a touch here
not these guys though because I always
like Oh Logan Paul is like a total
psycho
and he's just trying to be like
relatable yeah but our kids are actually
walking around saying ye that disturbs
me I I never thought about that I
thought they were let me ask the guys in
back or any of you guys friends with
young younger generation I I do not I'm
not personally friends with anyone who
on ironically uses heat alright what
about the other men back there anyone
that is my generation but I refuse to
talk like that no that's not your
generation I think they're younger than
you 14 yeah like 14 oh yeah but okay so
Zak do your contemporaries talk like
this [ __ ] now so that's not your
generation no but what would define my
generation people yeah people around
your age yeah no they don't talk like
that you just a loser dude right okay
let's go anyway dude you need to you
need to uh not lit bro you need to get a
more lit I don't know let's get off this
[Laughter]
be on fleek breakfast thank you
breakfast how can you how can your
breakfast be Gucci by the way thank you
to be super over
goals say by kaliesha and then testing
stress weather's gonna be tarnished
right Chris yeah the [ __ ] hazmat
suits for that one do feel like future
yes alright well I hope you guys all got
perked up and ready to slay today on to
some other other really funny stuff the
Pope you guys may have heard does not
like his ring being kissed and there was
a recent videos being circulated of a
lot of people saying hello to the Pope
you know he's the Pope he's like he's
the guy so people want to kiss his ring
I personally never liked anyone that
much but I'm open to it I mean if you're
willing to kiss someone's ring what else
are you willing to do for them you know
it's the it's the Pope's ring it's not
just a ring right well but my point
remains like what would you do for
someone whose ring you're willing to
kiss pretty much anything that's
frightening but be that as it may there
kissing the guy's ring and apparently we
were trying to figure out why he was
doing this he was pulling away his hand
from them like very violently very like
he was knocked down that's so so so
apparently a little backstory here on
this Pope incident 14 people shook
Pope's Francis hand without bowing down
to kiss his ring then 41 people he got
all the stats on this 41 people bowed
down and kissed the ring but then all of
a sudden they started bowing down and
kissing the ring and the Pope was not
down after 10 minutes the Pope's
behavior changed he started pulling away
violently the Vatican said afterwards
that the Pope was concerned about
hygiene that's kind of an interesting
point because if you have like a
thousand people kissing your ring first
of all it's not healthy for them
and that's all it is an old guy don't
kiss my ring by not finally always
worried for them oh he was yeah I don't
buy that what about the first time
people you don't become the pulp unless
you're ready to have your ring kissed a
little bit right like come on you know
what's in you know it's part of the job
people can kiss you're in I make these
guys kiss my ring when I come in every
morning and I don't care which ring
cuz I don't see one it's the Matt kiss
the ring it's magic but nobody's gotten
sick as far as I'm aware he's like [ __ ]
you dude I'm over this [ __ ]
no [ __ ] no kissing the ring oh that's
so he didn't cut contact [ __ ] girl you
look nasty
not even close see some people some
people he doesn't allow clothes so you
tie balls them and he's like this [ __ ]
looks nasty
I'm keeping her lips away from Irene
Jesus is over watching the whole damn
thing not funny when the drop
I don't think so [ __ ] keep on good look
at this guy's so upset like they keep
going for it though it's clearly
something that they all expected to be
doing right they have that expectation
they're gonna kiss the ring they're
giving their respect yeah I think that's
like a really yeah so it's kind of a
strange thing to be like nah Doug no
today and then the fit the smile on his
face is clearly not genuine because you
cannot be on one hand happy to see
people get on the other hand pulling
violently away you know they mean what's
going through his head right now
hi SIA don't kiss the ring [ __ ] you're
not worthy
he's like moving along idiot he's not
even acknowledging him hi I'm the Pope I
got time for your [ __ ] can't save you
dude up to Jesus a little bit along guys
will get along fell to your priest man I
got this business to pitch to we're
selling you want to sell holy water
online now get in on this Ince we got
Instagram ads and everything that's so
true huh they're wearing the same shirt
to these bozos yeah pups like listen
move it along tell it to your priest I
can't save you
move it along guys as people get King
kinematic oh that's it
I could watch this all day I could watch
ten minutes of that can we watch it
again I think we get the idea is there
entertainment value in watching that
again probably not okay well that's good
that's fine because I have other related
videos so I loved it I loved Pope stuff
I think I find hope stuff funny like
does the Pope [ __ ] in the woods either
says hey Ethan do you want to order a
pizza
does the Pope [ __ ] in the woods but then
that evolves does the Pope [ __ ] in his
own hat yeah makan wow that's a that's
really deep because obviously you know
he doesn't wear a yarmulke so what do
you call that they had on his head
what's called the loaf the Pope loaf I
don't know
I had big-ass Pope hat so there's other
similar videos for example I I just I
found out that I have a thing for
watching people pull their hands away
from being kissed on the ring Prince of
Morocco is not down for tab is hand
kissed either this kids a little [ __ ]
gangster dude watch how he's like
straight up owning these see you idiot
see you dumbass nice try loser Oh a
handshake I'll take that bye dumbass I'm
12 don't kiss me
he moves it so fast he's a game no he's
a slick dude how's it just repeating
that's interesting but this kid is a
slick guy and he's right he's a go kiss
my hand man I'll what are you got gloves
no what's the problem he's not he's not
wearing gloves no no it looks like grave
most like 10 pixels so sorry yeah look
how quick he pulls it away yeah yeah
yeah I love it
he's a weak though I would just hold on
to his hand huh that's what Ian did to
me the other day I try to pull my hand
away because I make him kiss the ring
and he held on tight iron grip that guy
um here's another clock this is the
first video I saw of someone pulling the
the hand away this looks like some mega
church were there they just make like a
freakin trillion dollars to exorcise
some like some lady in a wheelchair he
pulls his ring away and then he he puts
his hand over her face and pushes her
head up that was gnarly wasn't it yeah
she's like no [ __ ] so giving them books
I don't know what's going on here how
much does they think I'm not actually a
bunch of donations that might be cash
wait where's cash in those envelopes oh
so they give him a bunch of money and he
gives him some buck please just let me
know this is the hand shoves him in the
face man I love I gotta get into
religion man these guys know how to make
a buck I'll tell you what for real these
guys are good
and you they even want to kiss your hand
though they take your money and they
love it so much they want to kiss your
[ __ ] ring I'm in the wrong field man
see when I transfer like here's $1,000
here's all of my money here's all of my
money there's one guy that actually gets
to kiss his hand and he's beaming
he's like I did it dude I'm gonna win
the lottery he's gonna get hepatitis
actually the guy the tall guy in the
block must be good fit
he nails that he gets him he's quick and
he's strong what are we really that long
see oh my god he's slapping it's locked
in let's go back but he's doing he's
strong cuz he he basically hand raped
him it was yeah that's what he needed
this morning I slept in till let's watch
this so crap doesn't for the grab
he holds tight and he goes in it's like
a little yeah and any on his face is
like oh man what you just stole some of
my powers man oh come on dude fantastic
is it not gonna kiss your hand okay he's
like now [ __ ] just keep walking don't
even think about it lady he uses the
book to heal guys really he's at war and
we think about got no chill the thing is
he's kind of at war because he's taking
money he's giving books but he's also at
the same time using the books as shields
pushing heads slapping hands
it's just caught there at war with each
other right now over the hand game it
doesn't have the elegance to the Pope
n-no the Pope was honestly less elegant
the Pope was at was at war Pope was less
I got this guy's slapping people well
sure but the Pope was like I like
fighting the Pope looked like he was on
edge because he had that smile on but it
was like it looked like he was about to
break to me to each his own but the Pope
was falling apart in my eyes one minute
from stabbing someone
this guy's not fronting though he's
slapping people in the face he sees
for five minutes before he clocked the
guy he didn't drop him out they had to
pull him out with uh on a stretcher
don't kiss the [ __ ] ring I dare you
to kiss the ring oh did you it's a game
they play but she goes and hard if you
guys have any more Pope she's kissing
the ring [ __ ]
I loved I'll watch it for hours Podcast
said ACH recom fantastic guys I was on
my home page on YouTube the other day I
don't know what I did to deserve this I
had this recommendation on my home page
that blew my mind and I know where your
guys's minds go what were you watching
to get this I wasn't watching anything
to get this I don't care about baseball
and I definitely don't watch gay ass
videos I mean I barely what the hell do
i watch I don't want you I watch like
science channels so was it my surprise
when this shows up at the top of my
homepage look at this [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
are you doing YouTube Anthony rector's
amazing ass with a baseball and a peach
what's the problem and you could see is
nutsack well I don't know but that that
yeah probably but the way that the pants
fold is crazy I was like what and the
vid the videos bye Wibbly Gaylord
actually quite a bit of views 240,000 11
months ago though but they dug this up
from 11 months ago to serve this on my
home page if I have never watched Wibbly
Gaylord I promise I don't know
well cuz so I looked at the comments on
this video and like one comment was like
look I know I'm gay but why are you
rubbing this in my face YouTube so what
you're saying that oh something about me
that I don't maybe
the algorithm is getting smarter and
smarter they're like good there's no
other gay [ __ ] on my homepage everything
was normal except this one video and I
was like why the [ __ ] you guys want to
watch this thing of course maybe they're
like Ethan has he needs a little push to
discover himself
I got a media music here hmm no no no
nope nope oh my god we got almost got
claimed someone owns that drum snare
here we go yeah so this is record thanks
you believe this is on my boob right now
yeah this is a thing on YouTube you can
recommend it to me is it I don't know it
looks like a normal can you turn down
the music very loud me trying to record
look at this
this guy's gotta said to him we're about
it - for Christ's sake what do you think
you how do you rate that ass you can be
honest
is it a peep no you're not a ass you're
not a ass girl well I'll tell you what
when I saw that I was like I would walk
and tear that ass that's why you gotta
recommend it this guy is such a
character man look it works because of
all the memes about how you have to take
ass but how would they know that that
was me they're like oh Ethan of h3 thick
ass let's serve him specifically as
videos I guess that seems kind of crazy
though but anyway yeah my my I can only
take so much of Anthony Richter's
amazing ass
[Music]
thanks for saying are you a dick girl or
ask because you know they say tits or
ass - guys I don't know that there's big
girls so are you a dick girl or an ass
girl I'm a dick girl okay
so let's go to one of our headline
stories here this is a juicy hot hot hot
very culturally culturally relevant
scoop here for you guys
surviving cardi B now you all know
because we've talked about here on this
show
surviving our Kelly is a story that's
been dear to our heart we follow closely
as you all we'll know the do you have
your passport do you have your shots do
you want to come with Rob to America now
we've got cardi B getting into the mix
she someone dug up a alive Instagram
live from three years ago
mm-hm in which she confesses to drugging
and robbing people Wow well you know
being living that life she used to work
as a stripper yeah you know I strippers
make a lot of money right yeah so I
don't know that I don't know if you're
like successful she was I think she was
so I don't know she says she needed the
money
but I think stripping really you you
make a lot money from stripping like
really like hundreds of thousands even a
shitty one probably Wow she need to get
that um ass surgery done that stuff
costs money I saw someone else pull a
video around the same time saying that
she back then had already had a house
and ass and tits well she says she
needed the money for studio time like
she's talking about in the context of
building a career right hired ok
engineers and rent the space and
everything she's right okay so there you
have it
so she didn't need the money she clearly
I mean once you end this video which
I'll show you guys she's crying she's
very upset about what she had to go
through to get where she is and I will
say to her I don't want to say defense
but cardi B I don't think there was ever
a pretense that she was anything but
that right people like her because they
like her music but she's always been
upfront that she I mean she's not a
saint she's not a good person she came
from a street life she was a prostitute
a criminal stripper a stripper I'm not a
prostitute I'm sorry that's not what I
meant to say a stripper and and she's
been dripper but the context of the
story is that she was like also
prostituting right I guess so yeah I
guess you're right
a lot of strippers do that you know on
the side basically so there so there can
be sex in the champagne room I was an
aside here I got maybe I won't go this
maybe I won't go this route okay let's
let's skip this aside for now
so in this store so I'll say it's not
like a lot I've seen people comparing it
to Bill Cosby now Bill Cosby first of
all his persona was that he was the most
wholesome dad in America he was mister
and he also had this holier-than-thou of
like black people need to bootstrap
themselves out and saves themselves out
of poverty by working hard right and
meanwhile this guy has decades of of
rape systemic drugging and rape and
abusing his power and taking advantage
of people that the trusted him he would
mislead people to thinking that he could
help their career take him back home and
rape them so I do think that's a little
different than going home with some
ghetto stripper yeah and he's like he's
got this clean image cardi B never had a
clean this is exactly
said she was is really like but that's
kind of what people like about her she's
really exactly raw people like her music
and so and she's so much forthcoming
about it that this is something she
actually confessed three years ago it's
not like Bill Cosby being like I raped
so many girls man I got a problem with
sex and I just keep raping people yeah
Dan is saying show the video and go to
brick do you like do you not like when I
read your notes damn I don't like it oh
because it well how can I get knowledge
it's hard for me not to acknowledge it
because my attention gets switched I
apologize I was just trying to look I
don't know not apologize it's good the
notes are great I think you don't need
to read it out loud that's why we're
writing it we wanted to say it out loud
we would say I need to learn to
multitask my brain we have a microphone
and which is not too deep back he can
the peek behind the curtain has so it's
different from Bill Cosby in my opinion
now I'm not saying it's not an awful
thing so I want to make that very clear
there's an awful awful thing to a
drugged and robbed somebody sure of
course that's awful and and if people
and if the police want to open an
investigation like they did on Bill
Cosby and and and investigate people who
are coming forward saying they've been a
victim of hers let's do that not saying
let's not go down that route I just
think that it's so not and then the
other comparison is are Kelly and again
are Kelly again it's like a systemic
abuse over decades and decades I mean
he's an Ethiopian we should listen it to
it first before we I'm going to
conclusions yes well I won't give some
context but there we go
make turn off the mute yeah this look at
this [ __ ] cardi B I missed using sex and
to drug and Rob men for their money how
much text and then there's wing we know
gang tea and gossip Tina what the hell
gosh I then at messy Queen
so and so like how many people have
water my watermark this if we get a shoe
podcast watermark on this will be upload
it so loud someone else's money you
spell it
[Music]
[Music]
that's have weird flux to be honest
because she's going I did it myself
and I robbed a bunch of people also
stripping I is commendable you know I
appreciate that that's not an easy job
but he was saying don't pause it okay
[Music]
[Music]
nobody wanted to [ __ ] me to help I feel
like man that was a weird place to go
and also she's very difficult to listen
to very raspy voice something about the
audio in that because it's been reloaded
like 42 echoey room
well let's not go to a break because
we're at at 11 we're at you know the the
30 minute mark we'll come back and we
will discuss surviving cardi B within
this sim card is the power to save
hundreds of dollars well I don't know
how much you pay for your wireless bill
but chances are it's way too much okay
mint Mobile is empowering you to get the
same great speeds and pay way less
thanks to me at mobile you don't have to
overpay for wireless anymore you can cut
your wireless bill down to just 15 bucks
I bought they've reimagined Wireless
making it easy and online-only which
means that they passed the significant
savings on to you directly now look at
this beautiful little card as I tell
talk to you more mint mobile makes it
easy to cut down your wife's bill from
just 15 bucks a month use your own phone
with any mint mobile plan you can keep
your old phone and number along with all
of your existing contents boom all you
do is pop that baby in you know how we
do it with mobile you choose between
three eight and twelve gigabytes of 4G
LTE data and you stop paying for them I
mean it data that you never use
because all those big boys all of a
sudden oh now we want to sell you
unlimited data he's gonna cost $500 a
month
eat [ __ ] [ __ ] mint mobile every plan
comes with unlimited nationwide talk and
text
now we're talking and texting and if
you're not 100 percent satisfactorily
covered with their 7 date money-back
guarantee what have you got to lose
accept tons of money to these big boys
that are taking advantage of you
ditch your old wireless bill and start
saving today with mint mobile so right
now to get your new wireless plan for
just 50
dollars a month and get that plant
shipped to your door for free go to MIT
mobile comm slash h3 that's mint mobile
comm slash h3 cut your wireless bill to
$15 a month you get free shipping on
your MIT mobile plan go to MIT mobile
comm slash h3 admit it you think that
cybercrime is something that happens to
other people you may think that no one
wants your data because you're broke and
you have no money to steal but guess
what hackers can grab your password or
credit card details and you'd be wrong
because someday you're gonna make money
and they're gonna be hiding in the
shadow waiting for your broke ass to be
a rich ass and that's when they've got
you in their palm of their hands because
they got your credit card number they
got your passwords they got your social
security number it doesn't matter if
you're broke now baby because they gonna
get you someday somehow and that's why
you need expressvpn because you leave
your internet connection unencrypted you
might as well be writing your password a
credit card number on a huge billboard
for the Western world to see that's why
you need to protect yourself from cyber
criminals to end-use expressvpn
expressvpn secures and then in mises
your internet browsing by encrypting
your data and hiding your public IP
address expressvpn as easy to use apps
don't seamlessly the background of your
computer phone or tablet
turning on expressvpn protection only
takes one click using expressvpn I could
safely surf on public Wi-Fi without
being snooped on or having my personal
data stolen and for just less than seven
dollars a month you get the same experts
VPN protection then I use for my own
internet expressvpn is rated number one
VPN service my tech radar and it comes
with a 30-day money-back guarantee so
what do you got to lose give it a shot
you can feel a lot safer it's like
putting a condom on your internet
browsing you can feel a lot safer you'll
be a lot happier after you've used it so
here's the deal
protect your online activity right now
today and find out how you could get
three months free by going to expressvpn
com / h3 that's expr ESS VPN comp
/ h 3 for a 3 month free with a one-year
package visit expressvpn cobb / HP to
learn more
you spend 90% of your life in underwear
so don't you think you owe it to
yourself to make sure you're wearing the
softest most beautiful luscious
underwear in the town that's why I only
personally wear me undies if you have
ever considered mega wedging yourself or
going total all out one piece excuse me
you can see everything
nothing you haven't seen but like
there's some people dude this is
flexibility this is comfort on levels
never before achieved if you can do this
then you know this should have softly
breathable flexible as it gets this is
me undies quality all right that's why
me and DS are so soft is because they're
made of that beautiful micro modal
fabric which is a full three times
softer than cotton and not only will you
feel like your loins are being hugged by
joy itself beyond DS gives multiple
options of styles for men and women and
like a crazy kooky all kinds of fun
colorful patterns so that you can
express yourself because I know you've
got a personality that's dying to get
out men can now try the new boxer brief
with fly which is the same great cut as
boxer briefs and now with an added
option for guys who prefer to go through
the gate versus over the fence there you
go I go over the fence personally but
some guys go through the gate and that's
okay most guys probably go through the
gate I'm a weird one I know guy who used
to pee out down the leg he wouldn't let
me just put his dick out down the leg I
was like that's a weird one but hey
tisha zone me ADIZ has a great offer for
my listeners for any first-time
purchaser when you go to me undies you
get 15% off and free shipping you get
50% off a pair of the most comfortable
undies you will ever put on and guess
what there's 100% satisfaction
guaranteed so if you don't like it you
get your money back if it's not the
comfortable best pair underwear you ever
graced on your dick and balls and ass
crack then you send it back they burn it
you get your money back
Mandy's comm slash make sure you got 15%
off your first pair free shipping and
100% satisfaction guaranteed
that's me Andy's comm slash h3
reviews are such an important part of
experiencing the internet weary reviews
on everything we buy so why I ask you
heel a-- should software be any
different software we spend more money
on we spend more time on so why aren't
we making sure we're getting the right
and exact and the best software possible
that's the beauty of kaptara comm / h3
you get real software reviews and find
the right software for your business
kaptara is the leading free online
resource to help you find the best
software solutions for your business
they've got over seven hundred and fifty
thousand reviews of products from real
software users discover everything you
need to make an informed decision search
more than seven hundred specific
categories of software everything from
project management to email marketing to
yoga studio management software that is
niche no matter what kind of software
your business needs kaptara
makes it easy to discover the right
solution fast join the millions of
people who use kaptara each month to
find the right tools for their business
for example we were looking for as good
scheduling software amongst our
companies amongst ourselves air table
was the one that we found which is a
calendar that we can share amongst
ourselves and has all the tasks it's
really useful and that's the beautiful
thing about it when you go to kaptara
you type a category a niche genre and
you're almost certainly gonna find a
software with reviews that it's gonna be
the perfect fit for exactly what you
need it's extremely valuable visit
kaptara kampf / h3 for free today to
find the tools to make an informed
self-aware decision for your business
kaptara comp / h-street that's spelled
capt erra dot-com / h3 kaptara software
selection simplified we are back and we
are surviving cardi B and we wash just
watch the video of her confessing to
drugging and robbing men yeah so we're
kind of just I've seen a lot of outrage
on social media directed towards her
justifiably I mean an awful thing to do
now she responded there's a lot here to
go she responded and then a guy came out
saying that he was one of her victims so
getting that here's her response to it
she says all I can do now is be better a
better me for myself my family and my
future so I'm seeing on social media
that alive I did three years ago I was
popped back up I live where I talked
about things I had to do in my past
right or wrong that I felt I needed to
do to make a living I never claimed to
be perfect or come from perfect world
wit a perfect past I always speak my
truth I always own my [ __ ] I'm a part of
hip-hop culture where you can talk about
where you come from talk about the wrong
things you had to do to get where you
are there are rappers that glorify
murder violence drugs from robbing
crimes that they feel they had to do to
survive
I never glorified the things I brought
up in that live I never even put those
things in my music because I'm not proud
of it and feel responsibility not to
glorify it I made the choice that I did
at the time because I had my limited
options I was blessed to have been able
to rise from that but so many women have
not whether or not they were poor
choices at the time I did what I had to
do to survive the men I spoke about in
my life were men that I dated that I was
involved with men that were conscious
willing and aware I have a past that I
can't change we all do that last part
about the men being conscious willing
and aware is does not make any sense
does it the part that makes it also
debatable because it's not really an
apology at that point oh she's not
really apologizing she's just saying
like I never felt good about doing this
but she's popping our find it she's
copying out by saying they were
conscious willing and aware like she
said she would drug them and rob them
who's willing to be robbed no I think
what she means it's like it wasn't rape
Oh what she's trying to say oh I didn't
yeah see I I didn't know that rape was
part of this conversation at all but
according to this so by this guy's
recollection his name is Kevin Smith
which sounds like a fake name I know but
apparently he's a real dude what's the
source for this meow
the hell is that then miss reputable ow
it was getting reported in a few places
okay the link that I cool so two days
after the video surfaced a New York
resident named Kevin Smith came forward
confirming the singer's claim in the
video Smith claimed that he had once
invited cardi B back to his room because
he was feeling her quote and then went
to the bathroom I've been drinking so I
had to piss I slid into the bathroom and
came back and finished my drink
last thing I remember she was twerking
on me music blasting sounds like a great
time and that was it the next morning I
saw a used condom on the floor and I
noticed all the cash I had which was
$850 and a Louis Vuitton belt and my
iPod Touch was missing he added I tried
calling her several times but I soon
realized she gave me a Google Voice
number I know she did it but I couldn't
prove it so I never went to file charges
mainly because I did not want my fiance
to know what happened
so I touched the help what a guy
laughing she gave me a Google Voice
number so I never went to the police
also I had a fiance at the time I'd say
good guy what a [ __ ] guy what a guy
you know I'm having a hard time
sympathizing with that guy but that but
okay let's be really that guy says first
of all there's something troubling here
that she drugged him and then presumably
had sex with them yeah so then then
comes the question what I imagine
happened is like before so when you take
a drug you're still conscious and and in
control of your facilities but you kind
of slip out and your memory can be irate
like if you take a xanax you know you
can be fully aware or in control for two
hours but when you wake up you don't
remember anything
yeah for sure like on flights yeah I
mean I can be completely functioning but
I won't remember it at all yeah but then
to say that he was willing to have sex
in that state of mind it's kind of
questionable I don't
well sure you did said exactly so a lot
of people would say that well that's
rape if they're drugged I mean that
happens a lot to men who have sex with
drunk girls on college campuses now a
lot of they'll say if she's drunk is
rape
so by those standards you know and also
she's the one admitted administering the
drug so like if she you know if she
drugs you and you lose awareness like
she could have [ __ ] warts coming out
of her vagina and you'd be like dude I
don't want to put my dick in that like
there's there's a dissent I that you
know
eally you're not there with me maybe the
maybe something there but I'm saying
maybe you see something there that you
don't want to put your dick in you mean
he couldn't make a decision and could
not make the decision yes yes maybe
maybe it was super nasty super long hair
stinky and worms out of the hole I think
cardi she keeps it clean I'm not sure
about that at any rate it is all very
very debatable but one thing's for
certain I think your fiance knows now
[Laughter]
but it's really interesting too if the
roles were changed and if it was a guy
who did it to a girl yeah I would
definitely be like [ __ ] about every
won't be super outraged so I don't know
so you've got to be treated the same
know you've got a guy at a strip joint
it's probably a really seedy nasty strip
joint cigarette stinks of cigarettes
there when they're struck she goes hey
let's go back to your place I mean he's
definitely going there with the
intention of something but having said
there's no debate but not with the
intention of being drugs no of course
not and by the way he's is so so that I
think the setting is interesting so he's
a guy taking a stripper and
seedy strip joint back to his place of
course he's not signing up or consenting
to be drugged and robbed I mean drugged
and robbed that's a huge violation
I mean imagine waking up and all your
[ __ ] is gone and you got the wrong
number I mean that's awful
even just having sex but having no
memory of it it's pretty horrible right
you don't know what happened yeah you
don't know what how badly it stunk he
doesn't like that
I don't okay but you want to see what
you're putting your dick in at least you
want some visual list of the problems
I'll make better give me Burke go with
it you know yeah I think it's it's not
good and what rubs me wrong too is how
she's like I had to do it all myself but
I mean let's not include this and that
bucket not good I rate it not good is it
as bad as Bill Cosby in our Kelly I
cannot say that it is I can't say that
it is but again I'm not saying if look I
think there's scale to things of
monstery yes I don't think everything is
black or white and I think like you know
it's not on the same level in my opinion
I mean Bill Cosby anarkali I don't they
ruined so many people's lives over the
course of many decades I mean that was
just treachery on like new levels a
stripper drugging and stealing someone's
money is is probably not that uncommon
and and that kind of scenario like a
really ghetto strip club you know what I
mean you're I would I would gamble your
tape I would be like dude there's like a
10% chance I wake up without a kidney in
the morning you know what I mean maybe
higher but when you go over to Bill
Cosby's house you're not you're like oh
oh the oh he's gonna roofie me that's
not that's why anywhere in your mind and
you're not trying to [ __ ] or anything
you just want to meet Bill Cosby or
arrow or like if you're you're meeting
like in a professional setting like your
boat actors you know
right of course that's very different
yeah so this is bad and if people if the
police want to investigate and see how
bad it is and if she's been a seer if
she's done this a lot you know if she's
because a lot of prop like I mean let's
investigate if that's what the police
want to do if there's evidence I support
that
not saying no I'm just saying I don't
think that she ever pretended to be
anything but that I'm not if the victims
if those victims will come out and they
feel violated I mean yes press charges
baby get in there get justice but that
guy is like that guys said the twist
there yeah I just didn't have there
enough enough evidence to go to the
police also I didn't want my fiance to
know do you think there's any validity
at all to to what she's saying about you
know it not being uncommon in in hip-hop
for people to you know openly talk about
their criminal past and well that's kind
of a point of pride almost yeah I'm glad
you brought that up because that is a
good point because there are a lot of
rappers who have actually killed people
and rap about it and so we're willing to
say to them well that's your past yeah
that's just that's in your past and
you're living a good life and you're
rapping now so or like it's the rapper
image right that's cool for rappers to
be murderers and drug dealers right
shaven goes a step further and says that
she she's never talked about this in her
music because she's ashamed of it
whereas other artists actually make it
kind of like a centerpiece of their
lyricism is talking about their CD pass
mm-hmm
I mean it doesn't excuse what she did
but I think she is pointing out a
Apocrypha there well Shia and I and I do
think so yeah I mean it's this is
objectively much less much less bad than
murdering someone
but if murders funny in a way in our
minds we can forgive murder for some
reason of people of like in hip-hop
they're like oh well you know yeah he
killed yeah he had to he had to do it
I think it's just a you don't actually
take it literally yeah yeah
do we know of half rappers that have
killed people and working today
uh I mean I guess apparently they were
never caught for it right right and I
mean that's where it does get really
great because you know if it's in a song
you can always just say it's artistic
license you know where's the story right
this was sort of a candid moment that
you know it's hard to explain away as oh
I was just kidding or I was lying or
what but he doesn't seem to be saying
that it's a lie either
in her apology no yeah no no she owns it
right she doesn't say oh it's just
making [ __ ] up to sound hard which would
be the easy way out but um all of that
aside in a vacuum it sounds really bad
watching that video and her being like I
did it all myself and I had to rob
people and drugged them I was like oh
come on that's that's not something to
brag about cuz almost in a way she is
bragging because she's like look what I
had to do to survive so in a sense she
is kind of bragging about it yeah even
though she's crying as somebody she's
not like I work minimum wage at McDonald
yeah for five years now she was making
hundreds of thousand dollars stripping
she could have waited another year
mm-hmm and not robbed and drugged
someone and I think when it was just the
stripping people did kind of respect
that in a way yeah that's a real hustle
right exactly that is not an easy job
man I'll tell you what yeah
so there you have it that's cardi B
surviving cardi B now speaking of
surviving cardi B we've got a new are
Kelly video that popped up that is just
tremendous you guys this our Kelly story
I can't get over it he's on stage here
let me just show you this video we had
to blur it because it's honestly too
graphic but I'll tell you what what
you're missing out on you could probably
tell from the blur
but he goes up for the front stage and
he starts going wipe me down why me
and he presents his crotch and they
start grabbing his his junk and wiping
his junk and I mean well here watch for
yourself we blurred that part is so
graphic but you'll be able to tell wipe
my lips
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
wipe my comm I don't think your tongue
needs to be wiped up I think that's
supposed to be wearing he's loving it
he's powerful right now I love this this
is makes it into a song everything's a
song with our Kelly you could turn
anything into a song people in the back
like what's going on Dan this keep
wiping me song is sick I'm feeling it
keep flapping me keep wiping me yeah
here we go this magnitude though so he
presents his cross to them he bikes them
and swapping it and they're totally
there attaching it
oh yeah there's like 20 hands on his
dick right now look at his face he's
just presenting his dick and now he's
got a bigger smile on his face I think
he was kidding dude oh crap this was no
graphic yeah I almost wish that we could
show it I'm blurred because you just
it's out there
everybody watching and listening go go
watch the original after this you can
use your imagination I mean I love art
Kelly I love everything about our Kelly
the whole story the whole scoop it's
fantastic watch me now why not tongue
okay here we go everyone's tuning out
I'll spare him today thanks for the
thanks for the lay up though he
literally sticks his crotch out she
starts like humping vigorously yeah and
struggling his dick - he starts jiggling
his dick though the girls love it man
they were in that just shows you how
easy it is to start a sex cult when
you're like a single like that got
singers get so much ass dude it's
ridiculous it's insane like they don't
even think about it I mean just in this
video all this oh these are these are
what I would have to imagine normal
otherwise normal people that all the
sudden are Kelly's dicks in their face
when they've got it and they're grabbing
it yeah they probably have kids and [ __ ]
that one girl in the back was up what is
here baby was here so weird I did the
whole fame obsession I don't know like
the celebrity thing celebrity worship
yeah do or [ __ ] it's pretty sick
strangely yeah you look really beautiful
today you know when I was thinking about
women grabbing our toes looking at you
and I was like damn your hair's crazy
you look like radiant beautiful I don't
feel like your eyes are sparkling your
sweaters fire it's all going on I just
feel like heavy all the time and tired
well you are massive you hide it really
well but Yili is getting massive her
stomach is getting like rock-hard - it's
really hard I don't know if people if
you would think about it buddy I didn't
really think it would be it's like
really hard hard when you touch it yeah
do you know that you're having a crazy
hair day right now
no dude your hair looks [ __ ] bump and
you got like a fold right here that
looks really good it's fire hair day
thank you
yeah the pregnancy things crazy but ela
hides it so much that I swear God some a
lot of days I don't even I continually
don't even know sometimes that she's
right
yeah I'll say it's only been in the last
like maybe two weeks
it's like noticeable to me you know what
I mean it's funny because I'm like at
the end well yeah I mean it's we only
have like two months left yeah that's if
it lasts the whole way no you can grab
them before humble not well maybe like
three weeks early yeah like not a lot of
times well that's where at the doctor I
was like just out of curiosity when can
the baby come out and still be alive I
think I said this but I did yeah but I
was but it that was like a long time ago
so that baby is ready to live already
he's just chilling yeah it's weird I can
just walk walk around and then I feel
like feeling move in mm-hmm
it's like I'm carrying a creature here
you are so weird
but it's getting firmer which means this
must be so tight and there it's like
super cramped dude it a little Theodore
it's just like oh yeah but I guess he's
comfortable I think so it's so weird
that they don't cry in there only when
they come out you know what I heard that
they do what the that they could heat
crying there no and that you can hear it
oh but they're underwater I just saw it
online and I was like I don't know if
this is real I've never heard I don't
like reading anything about the
pregnancy I've heard that you can hear
them burp or hiccup feel it yeah have
you felt that anything like that no I
feel little movements I wonder if that's
what they mean like first sounds like
from what I heard is that it's very
obvious when they burp are hiccup what
MD says that they they can indeed cry in
the world yeah oh my god and WebMD is
never wrong so they've diagnosed my
cancer so many times oh my god they can
cry that is so terrifying yeah yeah I
didn't like knowing that and I
immediately closed it when I saw it
because I was thinking I was like how
weird is it that they just they don't
cry and then when they come out they cry
yeah and I like I started going down
that
I saw someone said that you could
apparently hear it even and that's when
I closed it that's so sad what do you do
when your baby's crying in your womb a
lot about it yeah I haven't read
anything I don't want to watch any
videos about birth um I don't want I
just I don't know why I just feel like I
don't I felt well there's a lot of feels
like too much information and I want
there's a lot of and there's a lot of
[ __ ] to scare you too yeah and I feel I
feel like that's a good inclination we
have people around us helping us who
know what they're doing
yeah we have a my sister already had
three kids so what do people who are
listening being like oh don't you want
to know how to take care of your baby
I've taken care of a lot of babies yeah
I've got you I have no nothing I've
worked as a babysitter and I like I'm in
for I'm in for it although I swear to
God raising shredder I [ __ ] I do all
the crazy [ __ ] man I wipe his ass I
shower him I gotta clean his dick and
balls in the shower and everything I've
been there yeah taking care of him do
you know how to change a diaper Ethan
never in my life and I never changed a
diaper man I I can show you that part I
can't imagine that it's you know much to
it I'm not like a diaper to know it is
anything I put a diaper on myself but we
have we have we've got help which is
nice we've got what do you call it the
lady who do a lot a doula yeah so that's
someone that basically is there before
during and after the birth yeah as a
help coach like on breastfeeding and
there during the birth to like that
plane yeah because my mom's not gonna be
here I mean she'll come visit but you
know not having your mom near you is the
main issue hmm so I think they do I will
be good I was gonna be great
we've she's she's fantastic she's like a
baby wizard so yeah that's gonna be
great so that takes a lot of the
pressure off
I can't believe that Theodore can cry in
there that's true I don't want to know
that you're right yeah I want to know
that see that's why I don't read
anything that it scares me I feel sad I
like knowing that he's like comfortable
in there that's what I thought and
that's what I want to think isn't it
crazy though like how then the ultimate
metaphor for life
you come yanked out of a warm
comfortable place crying you're you're
cold you're all miserable you're
confused you're crying they say that the
baby Christ because the first breath of
air they take hurts it's painful like
daggers in there because inside there
and reading like liquid there's no
breathing there's no brain yeah
confusing awful horrible moment
traumatic you know that's it we all come
it's traumatizing to be born is it
sounds traumatic mm yanked out of a
little hole people are saying you can't
cry I don't know if you guys want to
look it up and then look at me y'all
gonna argue with that
it's the ultimate authority I believe
the people who say that he can't cry
because that's what ya wanna believe
Jesse Smollett I got a lot here just you
smell it anyway you look very excited
about the baby two months you look II
look like crazy hair day to day crazy
Jesse's smaller everyone in the comments
agrees right yes of course they know so
so Jesse Smollett has captivated the
minds in the hearts of this entire
nation
Jesse Smollett was an actor on a popular
show Empire he actually was making a lot
of money on that show reportedly like 2
million dollars a year Wow he was making
like something like $150,000 per episode
so he was very compensated black gay
dude let me just do a brief recap for
people who are not caught up and or
people who need to refresh their memory
he first reported that he received a
envelope with a powdery substance and
accrued
drawing of a man hanging from a tree
with a gun pointed at him he says that
it said Magga on the return form one
leek later Smollett reported getting
jumped in the early morning hours in
downtown Chicago by two masked
individuals hurling racist and anti-gay
slurs they physically assaulted him
according to the actor beating him out
pouring a chemical on him and wrapping a
rope around his neck before fleeing he
later checked himself in the hospital
with minor injuries that's almost like a
parody of a racial attack like they're
walking around with a rope and Shia and
bleach sent himself that so what the
police say happened is that he sent
himself the letter and when it did not
get the attention he wanted he paid two
dudes $3,500 to stage the attack the
authorities say they have got ample
evidence including suspicious text
messages surveillance footage and a copy
of the check he paid to the brothers the
actual check [ __ ] paid in the
checklist crime 101 I mean with a check
made out to the people that attacked him
it's kind of hard to dispute that the
brothers themselves also implicated
similar and said yeah he paid us it was
a whole stunt and apparently it's
because he thought that he was not being
compensated enough on his show he wanted
you know sympathy and support and I
think he thought that it would make him
a star because a lot of the times when
you get in the center of media attention
and especially when you're the victim of
something terrible all the sudden you
know an overnight you can become a star
and I think that's what he was hoping
would happen
he's which is just kind of ironic
considering he was sitting so pretty you
know so I'm sure a lot of you especially
American listeners have followed this
story because it's just really dominated
the news because
well first first this story came out and
everyone believed him and it's thought
it awful it was like oh my god and I had
this whole Magga element and it was just
like a powder keg but he somebody put a
noose around his neck and it was a hate
crime and they hate him because he was
gay and black and is like it was it
sounded so awful but then it started
twisting and the police started
investigating that maybe he had faked
and staged the crime itself so from the
beginning the media story was just it
was so compelling it was so outrageous
so then what's even more outrageous is
that a black gay man would use these
people use the racism in the Magga and
the homophobia to try to uplift himself
and use it to his own game I mean the to
pervert justice like that is even more
twisted than the attack he allegedly
said happened yeah I mean how create I
mean you know the problem the big
problem with faking something like that
is now when other stuff like that
happens victims are less likely to be
believed yes he the gay community and
the black community really don't need
anything like that no God knows that
they get plenty of hate crimes already
but now he has single-handedly sown a
seed of doubt he's under minded those
communities so so badly such an awful
treacherous crime
honestly just treachery really it's so
bad so the police said after reviewing
so all the sudden he was being tried for
filing a fake police report and doing
all this [ __ ] he was in deep water with
the police and there was like like you
said there was plenty of evidence
apparently so any of evidence much like
obvious at this point that he lied they
were going to get a conviction yeah they
had a check for Christ's sake they had
surveillance they had text measures the
plot the police chief even did a press
conference being like this dude faked it
and this is BS and it undermines these
personalized groups so all the sudden he
shows up to court with a smile on his
face for an emergency hearing with the
court and the judge said after reviewing
all the facts and circumstances of the
case mr. Smollett Volland mr. Smollett
volunteer service in the community an
agreement to forfeit his ten thousand
dollar bond to the city of Chicago we
believe the outcome is a just
disproportionate and appropriate
resolution to this case and so basically
they dropped all the charges the
district attorney dropped for know for
no apparent reason out of nowhere
dropped all the charges and then on top
of that the judge sealed the case so
that the public could never know what
was actually in there mm-hmm Wow what
the Frick dude you know this is was such
a ballsy move because everybody hated
this guy it was no longer a political
thing the left and the right were both
like dude this guy needs to go down yeah
this was a horrible treacherous thing
that he did so he goes out his lawyers
go out and start giving press
conferences and interviews and [ __ ]
talking about oh he's innocent but
actually so the DA had to make a
clarified statement she said an
alternate disposition does not mean that
there were any problems or infirmities
with the case or the evidence we stand
behind the Chicago Police Department's
investigation and our decision to
approve and our decision to approve
charges in this case they explained the
and stressed that because we drop the
case does not exonerate Smollett yeah
it's so weird I just don't understand it
and I feel like after we dealt with our
lawsuit I have a better understanding of
how this stuff works and it puts this in
even such a worse light in knowing
because when we for example when we were
trying to come into agreements with Matt
ha
we were presented with some options of
like okay he'll drop the case and buy it
but it will be sealed and no one can
talk about it and the problem that we
had with it was that if no one can talk
about it no one will know if we were in
the right food were in the wrong and if
you're if you're innocent why would you
want that wouldn't you that so we knew
we were in a sense dude we didn't we
weren't okay with not being able to ever
talk about it that's not gonna give
anyone any answers right so I felt from
his perspective if you're innocent of
such an awful crime why would you want
to seal it and well it also says so when
you want to steal information you have
to make a petition to the judge and I
think also your your opponent mm-hmm
for example there was information in our
case that was sealed that was just
basically like private financial numbers
that they had subpoenaed in Discovery
and so we made a request to seal it and
the judge granted that so in this case
the the district attorney was the one
that dropped the charges so she was in
collusion with his attorneys so they
agreed together to seal it up yeah and
then what's even more confusing is that
now he's walking around telling people
that he's innocent I was innocent I
never lied which doesn't make any sense
on top of it because it goes back to
almost the Michael Jackson thing it's
like just because you weren't convicted
doesn't mean you're not innocent and in
this case the DA even had to go out and
make a statement and say you were not
exonerated yeah they're not saying like
the evidence was wrong no they're not
taking back n we just dropped it and we
don't know why so here he he held a
press conference right afterwards so
let's watch that TMZ baby
everybody everybody I just made a couple
notes first of all I want to thank my
family my friends the incredible people
of Chicago and all over the country in
the world who have prayed for me who
have supported me who've shown me so
much love no one will ever know how much
that has meant to me and I will forever
be grateful I want you to know that not
for a moment was it in vain
I've been truthful and consistent on
every single level since day one I would
not be my mother's son if I was capable
of one drop of what I was been accused
of this has been an incredibly difficult
time my mother the worst of my entire
life
but I'm a man of faith and I'm a man
that has knowledge of my history and I
would not bring my family our lives or
the movement through a fire like this I
just wouldn't so I want to thank my
legal counsel from the bottom of my
heart and I would also like to thank the
state of Illinois for attempting to do
what's right now I'd like nothing more
than to just get back to work I'm on
with my life but make no mistakes I will
always continue to fight for the justice
equality and betterment of marginalized
people everywhere so again thank you for
all the support thank you for faith and
thank you too god bless y'all thank you
very much so
Germany works for the lbgtq community
and the folks who said I am you that I
stand with you forever
yeah supported you throughout all of
this I love them I love them I'm one of
them saying I'm innocent even though
that you know dude that guy's not if
that guy acts again um I'm gonna be I'm
the Pope boy
yeah I'm pulling my hand right away from
that it's such a disconnect like
everything that he just said it's like
well it's so it's just so frustrating
because we're all so invested in this
miscarriage of justice and then all of a
sudden he shows up charges are dropped
sealed and he walks out and he's talking
about oh I'm innocent I never lied then
right afterwards the police chief and
the mayor of Chicago hold a joint press
conference to and and listen to this I
mean this is just explode like this is
the police chief
my personal opinion is that you all know
why I stand on this do I think justice
was served
no we're do I think justice is
I think this city is still old an
apology and let me digress for a month
when I came on this job I've been a
cotton out for about 31 years and I came
on this job I came on with my honor my
integrity and my reputation if someone
accused me of doing anything that was
circumvent that then I would want my day
in court here to clear my name
they won't makes him look like a real
idiot and we've been there too we wanted
we didn't want to not be able to talk
about it and no one knows who one who
was right who was wrong if you're
innocent you wanted to be known that
you're innocent right know that guys as
far as I could tell I don't know why the
police and the mayor would go out and
put their necks out I mean it seems like
they had in irrefutable evidence that he
was going down well even the judge in
and what she said is like oh well he did
some community service dan you were
saying that it's already been served he
doesn't need to do anything right it's
retroactive essentially they're just
they're crediting him for the fact that
he apparently has in the past done a lot
of community service and he had a ten
thousand dollar bail so they're like
they kept that what a joke
what is ten thousand for him it's
nothing well if he doesn't work for the
next 20 years it might be hmm what a
joke man what a joke
come on this crime was so bad was such a
heinous crime he committed so the so
here's the mayor speaking defective
units I'd like to remind everybody a
grand jury
this individual based on a only a piece
of the evidence that the police attica
collected in that period of time so
grand jury action brought the charges I
think on two things I'd like to serve
three things I like to say want
on financial cost us $10,000 doesn't
even come close to what the city spent
in resources to actually look over the
camera gather all the data gather all
information that actually brought the
indictment by the grand jury I'm many
many multiple different targets second
is what I would call the ethical cost
and yet you just because a person who
was in the House of Representatives
the Shepherd legislation they dealt with
hate crimes putting them on the books
that President Obama then signed into
law do they use those very laws and the
principles and values behind the Matthew
Shepard
hate crimes legislation to self promote
your career his advise a cost that comes
to all the individuals gay men and women
who will come forward and one day say
they were a victim of a hate crime who
not without it
people of faith Muslim or any other
religious faith will be a victim of fate
so you go they go out there and they
blast him basically right afterwards I
mean the mayor and the police chief come
on he makes a good point the guys robe
wealthy why we letting him off on ten
thousand dollars you know what I mean
well there's a late update to this story
just a couple hours ago actually on
Friday morning that city of Chicago is
now demanding that he pay one hundred
thirty thousand dollars to the city of
Chicago to cover the overtime hours from
the investigation and I got the letter
right here in front of units it's kind
of weird cuz that an attempt to resolve
this matter without further legal action
the city requires the immediate payment
of one hundred thirty thousand dollars
one hundred it's actually one hundred
and thirty thousand one hundred and six
dollars and fifteen cents mmm especially
that fifteen mhm expended on overtime
hours in the investigation this mountain
or blah blah blah if the amount is not
timely paid the Department of Law may
prosecute you for making a false
statement to the city wait they can
still go and do that I mean that's
this is an official this is Wow
that's crazy because if he pays it's
almost an admission of guilt right right
isn't it kind of weird though that
they're like basically shaking them down
I don't know to say that it's not just
that that scenario of pay the money or
we're gonna prosecute you it is kind of
weird to be like do this or this happens
I agree that kind of yeah extortionist
and that is kind of the way you would
either just do right if he if you guys
believe that he committed this crime
just charge it and charge him yeah
shake him down well apparently they did
but right it was someone above that yeah
the state attorney yeah right no they're
clearly pissed so here is when we get
interesting now these text message were
apparently leaked between this woman Kim
Fox who is the state attorney who was
who was in charge of
case overseeing this case against just
it and then genes what's his name Jesse
Jesse Smollett Justin guys got some
weird [ __ ] going on his name just a
little twist and then you've got Tina
that's a weird last name it's missing a
vowel in there how do you say that I'm
gonna assume the T is silent and it's
just chant Jen champion oh that makes
sense she's Asian I saw a picture Tina
probably not like that
so Tina is an influential politician a
chief of staff to Michelle Obama I'm
going right yes and by the way I don't I
the mayor also was chief of staff for
Obama so I think it's important I don't
think it's an Obama conspiracy I think
this lady who's Obama's on both theories
and conspiracy out there I haven't
looked into there's there I mean
apparently Michelle Obama was friends
with Jess it
oh she was directly again don't quote me
on that I might be wrong okay probably
wrong but either way let's just say
these are the facts
Tina is texting Kim who's in charge of
of prosecuting just sit now Dan how
concerned are these how confirmed are
these text messages they showed up down
TMZ yeah they showed up on TMZ which of
course was a little skeptical at first
but it has since been reported in the
Chicago Tribune and New York Times
like it it seems to be verified it's
widely disseminated and you know as
trashy as TMZ is the reporting is
usually pretty accurate yeah if you know
kind of hate TMZ but they don't lie
usually so so here how the f did they
get these text messages by the way the
freakin crazy story so big I don't know
why they thought that people would just
let it rest I know is the ballsiest all
did it ever so here's the day just hike
him I sent an email to your work address
I think I think is
well I wanted to give you a call on
behalf of Jesse Smollett and the family
I know they have concerns about the
investigation I'm bet they do you know
if I was his mom I would too I'm on an
8:00 a.m. flight to New York City but
please call me before then I land about
10:15 Chicago time my cell phone is many
things she says it like she owes her you
know I mean please she says it like call
me before then please call me before she
does like she's her boss or something
you know I mean is that there's a air of
dominance there
Kim responds spoke to the superintendent
Johnson I convinced him to reach out to
the FBI to ask that they take over the
investigation he's reaching out now and
we will get back to me shortly sent for
my iPhone
thank you I think Blanc is gonna call
you are they redacted I think Blanc is
gonna call you by the way the
superintendent Johnson referenced there
is the the gentleman the police officer
in that video
Oh intro he watched you so then she
responds thank you oh my god this would
be a huge victory
I make no guarantees but I'm trying I
understand I appreciate the efforts hey
hope all is well I wanted to check in
with you about what's happening here
when you have a moment okay are you
available to chat now yes okay calling
now so clearly clearly the person who is
in charge of prosecuting Jessi is you
have some sympathies his truck is in her
own words let's see
I make no guarantees but I'm trying and
response to this would be a huge victory
trying to undermine her own case hmm
I mean that is so shady hello what the
why are we trying to exonerate why we're
trying to let go this guy who committed
the most heinous crime so awful but then
this takes a hilarious twist ela you're
gonna love this
Jessie's lawyers go
on an interview on The Today Show she
maintains his innocence and claims wait
for it
what does she claim he saw the skin
surrounding their eyes was that a false
statement so he just to be clear he only
saw one of the attackers one of them he
didn't see he saw one through a ski mask
again he could not see their body
everything was covered and he had a full
ski mask on except the area around the
eyes he did tell police that he from
what he saw he thought it was pale skin
or white or pale skin was I think what
he said and that was what he and that's
why he initially did have a hard time
why did he say that he could've said I
don't know he could have but this again
he's the ocean Tyrell brothers what are
the chances that that's the case that he
saw somebody with light skin well you
know I mean I think there's obviously
you can disguise that you could put
makeup on there is actually
interestingly enough a video you know I
think police said minimal investigation
in this case it was it took me all of
five minutes to Google you know I was
looking up the brothers and one of the
first videos that showed up actually was
one of the brothers in Whiteface doing a
joker monologue the attackers were two
black guys that he knew and she's saying
well they may have been a white face so
that's how they're defending him now and
interestingly there was actually now
rumored to be a third attacker this is
his this is the picture they had oh [ __ ]
I'm wrong the joke well that's the
attacker in white failure that's they're
talking about yeah but here because that
doesn't and interestingly
white ELA there was rumored to be a
third attacker oh my god white face man
are you kidding that's not me that's
white face then she's seriously saying
that the guy beeps yes she for sure let
me pull this up now she found this photo
of him on social media and said oh well
dude he's in white face that if you say
eyes up close oh yeah so not
you know clearly I mean this story reeks
man it's so corrupt it's fair I've never
I've almost never in like in my life in
America experience corruption like on
this ad man under this spotlight under
this level of scrutiny and just shown up
he had a smile on his face when with the
court I am good thank you everyone for
believing me I'm innocent
I just want to move on with my career
also inches it's all so confusing this
statement that they release doesn't say
that is innocence why are you walking on
saying you're innocent well I hate to
say it but it's kind of like it's the
war on truth I mean Trump does the same
thing the DA's a statement said it does
not exonerate Trump but we did not have
the evidence to bring charges against of
collusion but we could not exonerate him
on obstruction of justice and now he
goes around saying I'm totally and fully
exonerated it's like you can say you
know there's no truth anymore
it's all spin well I think it's
interesting too with the smollett thing
you know I look around on Twitter and
stuff and on his social media and he's
got a ton of support
MPs surprised me well it did it to me at
first too but um you got to realize you
know I don't not from Chicago I don't
know a ton about it but Chicago is like
legendarily corrupt Chicago PD in
specifically the police are you know
worse than LAPD you know have a
reputation for being corrupt and you
know I'm not saying that he didn't do it
I seems pretty obvious that he did but
that's the problem when there's no
accountability is it this in the same
way that he's crying wolf with this hate
crime [ __ ] when the police are not
accountable to anything nobody believes
them when they are telling the truth you
know what I mean I mean everybody just
sticks to their guns are we talking
about on a national scale you support uh
I don't I mean he's I think so I mean
it's a national story that surprised me
because he's just you really undermine I
I think most people
both reactions but yeah for you for sure
if you go on social media you go to his
Twitter you got tons of fans saying [ __ ]
the police and I hope they're trying to
frame you they're trying to set you up
all that kind of stuff so I don't know
why then what the mayor has to gain by
going out there who's like an Obama
staffer oh for sure you know no I think
he did it
well again even his own even the the DA
that dropped the charges says I want to
make clear it does not exonerate him
well she basically says he's guilty she
says in exchange for his community
services ten thousand dollars if he
wasn't guilty why would they keep his
ten thousand dollars
they're letting basically what she's
saying is we're letting him off easy
you know community service in ten
thousand dollars that's your punishment
for the crime yeah the guy did it so
that's that was a whole story that was
like a whole freakin I was blown away
when I saw that on the news you know man
that guy I well let's see how this helps
his career which is original intention
first statement he's like the first
thing I'd like to do is go back to work
it's like yeah yeah good luck he I saw
him say that in a couple of different
statements he's clearly very like you
had it all dude you're young man you had
a great gig you were making millions of
dollars you had to take a frickin
shortcut you got off easy and you want
to go back to work you should go in a
hole and just [ __ ] disappear crazy
you should be in jail dude well I wonder
I mean is anybody gonna want to touch
this guy now no way lightning-rod yeah
dude no way I would I think I would
boycott if I saw him in a movie I
personally wouldn't want to support him
I can't imagine that it would be a
disaster
yeah it's an awful thing to do Barbra
Streisand Shaq Papa Instagram food we
got a lot left keep going 12:30 we have
somewhere to be at well we solved
I'm meeting my brother at 2:00 so we can
go for another half hour
mm-hmm so let's continue on on this
beautiful lovely Friday Barbra
Streisand's a weird she's a weird one
you guys Barbra Streisand I don't know
if you know who she is she's an old-time
singer very popular in her time very
wealthy she I was about to say that do
you but I don't know young people I know
I'm not very familiar with Barbra
Streisand what's the famous song of hers
you got me I'm mostly she was in a she
was an actress she was in a bunch of
movies oh pretty something pretty well
she's most original stars born that's
right mm-hmm she's most famous to me for
cloning her dogs one of her dogs pass
the ball at age and she cloned them and
she's just got a whole gaggle of cloned
dogs which I mean if you want to if you
want to know how out of touch a person
can possibly be with a normal life then
then feast your eyes on Barbra Streisand
with three cloned dogs and a face that
really is stopping to look human she's
got so much plastic surgery she's got
that inhuman look I mean obviously
that's probably photoshopped but oh and
that's she's like 75 but it's got that
puffy yeah surgery face Yeah right ELA
she does but she can't say she's not
looking good for the age well sure I
mean but Barbra seven she's 76
let me find an auto shop I should
probably injecting [ __ ] crazy baby
foreskin yeah
funny girl was the movie I was trying to
think of famous movie she was in she's
so much plastics for her lips start to
do this thing where it like wraps under
her teeth or something
yeah but it doesn't make you younger
people know that right it doesn't
actually make you younger you're still
old it's like who you kiddin actually
doesn't look that bad here
the plastic surgery and
that's beside the point look at those
cloned dogs man
the probably dumb is they're probably
dumb as dirt when you clone a dog commas
hurt I feel like there I Q my slow or
when you clone it would you clone
shredder I'll take one of those it's not
gonna be anything like him right you
can't read you can't see your key just
get another you can't be and it's also
like it's a desecration of the memory of
the real individual of the real shredder
he was there's only words only writer
exactly then you fall in love with him
with you can create a new relationship
with a new animal once you're over that
loss
I wouldn't clone shredder because
there's only one he's he is Fred I mean
the same it you could say the same for
any human being yeah I'll take a
shredder Cologne and call him splinter
don't can be arch-nemesis you will never
get a shredder clone yeah they do look
though I'm with you there she said of
the Michael Jackson allegations this was
the best take I've ever heard on this
she said that you couldn't you couldn't
specifically choose to say something
worse than this she says she believes
them okay so that's where she starts
it's I absolutely believe them and it's
too painful okay
she said of Wade Robinson and James safe
Chuck good so far and she goes on she
says but of Michael Jackson his sexual
needs were his sexual needs coming from
whatever childhood he has or whatever
DNA he has and she went on what she goes
on you could say molested but those
children as you heard them say
themselves they grew up and they had
kids and they thrived and they were
thrilled to be there with Michael they
both married and both had children so it
didn't kill them damn that's [ __ ] a
crazy-ass take wait you know who did
kill their father right both of it
that's Wow you're right that's such a
weird take dude oh my god she said they
were thrilled to be there I cannot
believe
that she said that they both were
married I had children so didn't kill
them and Michael just had to do what he
had to do because he wanted to [ __ ] kids
what why you can't make a worse taking
that it's like it happened and it's cool
and I'm ok with it if you went in a lab
and tried to take him like imagine the
bet worst take that would be it and she
was like if I have to blame anyone I'll
blame the parent mmm but not not Michael
not the one who committed the crime that
makes me wonder what is she doing in her
life she's like hey his cases is taste
and they were thrilled to be there like
I mean when this initially got reported
I don't even catch it until you just
said it but with Michael it's like it
might just be in his DNA
like what makes it sound like she knows
someone who people is analysis it's it's
genetic that you're a child molester
like well okay on that point I
understand because obviously nobody
would choose to be attracted to children
like it's a sickness yeah nobody would
choose to be attracted to children I
guess maybe and so poor choice of words
I guess well yeah no very poor
I mean I'm giving her the benefit of the
doubt here but she's saying his sexual
needs her sexual needs she's almost
saying look he's got a [ __ ] kid so
that's what he's gonna do but that last
sentence that look at didn't kill them
they were thrilled even to be there she
Ike's how could you watch the
documentary and come to that conclusion
seriously cuz she on one hand and admits
oh I believe them yeah yes
and then afterwards she posted an
apology of course I don't want to read
it no but I'm not gonna read it but the
last part of it she says whatever I'm
sorry
it shows the wrong words whatever
whatever for family sorry for any pain
or misunderstanding yada yada yada but
at the end she says I feel deep remorse
and I hope that James and Wade know that
I truly respect and admire them for
speaking their truth truth what can I
say yeah whose truth or whose truth
their truth she's like listen to your
truth you know I know you were thrilled
to be there at the time the
it almost make it like she's doubting
them it's like you're a story yeah it's
your story your truth and that's a
[ __ ] crazy take Barbara Streisand is
a weirdo she you know you guys have
probably heard the saying of the
Streisand effect that started from
Barbra Streisand this is an interesting
story
the term eluded to Barbra Streisand who
had sued photographer
Kenneth alderman for violation of her
privacy she tried she was suing for 50
million dollars and endeavored to remove
an aerial photograph of Streisand's
mansion from the publicly available
collection of 12000 California coastline
photographs Edelman's photograph the
beachfront property let me pull up the
picture actually that would be a even
perfect setting oh no I didn't take the
photo she lost yes she lost big time
photo Santa Barbara I'm so bad at
spelling this is like a joke so glad you
guys can't see my momma oh here it is
this is the photo okay big-ass mansion
on the dare
so I'll continue it was publicly
available from a collection of 12,000
photos of California coastal photographs
so it wasn't even a photograph of her
house was just a coastline in which her
house happened to be there
alderman photographed the beachfront
property to document coastal erosion as
part of the California coastal records
project which was intended to influence
government policymakers before Streisand
filed her lawsuit image 3 8 500 which
had her house in it had been downloaded
from Edelman's website only six times
two of those were downloaded by
Streisand's attorneys as a result of the
case public knowledge of the picture
increased greatly and it was downloaded
more than four hundred and twenty
thousand times then the lawsuit was
dismissed and Streisand was ordered to
pay the legal fees which amount to
hundred fifty thousand dollars that
means that she lost so egregiously at
her lawsuit the judge found to be so
egregious that she ordered her to pay
the other dudes legal expenses dude had
to pay 150 thousand dollars to defend
itself and that was back goddamn
long-ass time ago this [ __ ] is so
expensive so here's the picture nice
house and now here it is on my own now
here it is couldn't be seen by a million
people fantastic isn't it so that's the
Streisand effect I think it's something
interesting the Streisand effect if you
don't know is when you tried to remove
something from the internet that it
makes it more visible mm-hmm Papa John
Beck okay so we talked about this in our
new video Shaq becomes the new Papa this
was a weird one because we in our last
episode had this segment about how Shaq
we notices in every single commercial
and after that segment babajanian ounces
that checks the new Papa I mean what the
hell bending reality here on the h3
podcast he really isn't everything we
talked about this in our new video with
this freakish hands mm-hmm his hands are
freakish I mean dude look how small like
is that really a full-size basketball
right yeah I think the fans are that big
I mean this is equivalent basically the
guys have to be holding the supply huge
as nails are that is just his fingers
bigger than my dick its Papa John's it's
the Papa John here let's get to the
bottom of this Shaq holds a basketball
look oh yeah yeah god yeah damn that's
so crazy
I mean he's ready accurate yeah I don't
know I don't know what's going on here
these pictures are weird yeah that was
yeah I need bro that those are big yeah
and I can't get over that oh it's
probably yeah it's so that's good I
think it's the NBA ring for someone
knows like a house [ __ ] oh that would be
like a bracelet yeah looks like a
birdhouse
what if there's birds in there Papa John
so Shaq wrote a little letter a low love
note for Papa John I love this is that
story stop papajohns.com slash
Shaquille's story they're like you know
what we need after this whole n-word
fiasco a black dude pretty much yeah
pretty much I am so excited I am so
killing you I'm so excited I'm so
excited to be joining that's not a good
one his voice is super deep I'm so
excited to be joining now Papa's Jones
family not good huh as a member of the
board of directors you're not you don't
do [ __ ] on that board they paid him
eight million bucks to be the face
pretty good deal I would expect more
Shaq is worth I looked up he's worth
over 400 million dollars dude Shaq needs
to take a vacation these in these
general commercials how much does it
general pay him it's gotta be a drop in
the bucket 400 million take a vacation
dude
such a hustler you know I think Shaq is
just a hustle yes you know he wants to
to teach his kids penny saved is a penny
earned
yeah so hard it's a bike there's a paid
CIEE I want a pizza I don't work hard
it's Friday can we eat pizza don't I'm
thinking busing the music welcome to
Papa's house I'm so excited to be
joining the Papa John's family as a
member of the board of directors and
soon-to-be investor he's not even
invested yet he's like listen I'll
invest when she [ __ ] pay me the eight
million not putting my own money in that
[ __ ] you see the stock miss see the
stock of this company I'm not investing
[ __ ] for 20 years in the NBA my
basketball family were the biggest part
of my life however shortly after I
retired I decided to commit the same
level of hard work and passion and to
other things namely pizza no he said
including businesses which what brings
me here one of the key components of my
success is only investing in companies
and products that I believe in I'm a big
fan of Papa John's so he was a fan of
what Papa John Bill he's saying I am a
fan of Papa John John are John's he is a
plural both Explorer it's plural
see so that's the pizza he is the betta
now he is the man is the pizza no
there's on matter yes yes I love that
they are committed to making pizza with
high quality ingredients see Papa's
reading this in crime because he is that
he did that he's crying and he's got a
pizza and with one hand wiping the tears
left
it's got the box the last box with his
face on it he's got this music lubos I
did that I made the better ingredients
better listen to this Judas line
something I get to see firsthand when I
met CEO Steve Ritchie and made my own
pizza called The Shack aroni earlier
this year sorry Stevie CEO Stevie hasn't
been CEO that long he doesn't have [ __ ]
about high quality ingredients you think
you could put Stevie's face on that box
and they're gonna put shocked yes now
yes Shaq is gonna be on the face of
every pizza box
Papa John's ships out there having such
a crisis I'm telling you if they would
have just left Papa they would have been
over this and the stock would have been
back up yeah to where it was but there's
no pub of like the names gonna be Papa
John's buddy Shaquille eight million
bucks you can keep it going I like it
beyond the taste Steve was able to help
me understand what truly makes Papa
John's family so special namely the
coppice not eight million yes I checked
crazy dollars and Papa is not here that
dude hates black people great people
fresh ingredients and the vision for the
brand going forward Steve sounds like a
player preparing for a big game his
passion for the company its people is
authentic as the pepperoni slices on my
shakeela Shaquille what do you call it
Jesse chaccaron chaccaron chaccaron II
wonder what's honest record you know
that's gonna look up and check early to
discuss a car Oney it's probably a pizza
with like so many pepperonis you want
gag when you see it
by the way shot probably out large it's
probably like one slice for him because
my background I know that because every
large community there are thousand
people to put their hearts and souls
into bacon these pizza pies like the
delivery driver that got a big tip from
Papa rest in peace Bobby Jon is no
different and it struck a chord with me
s come on
this guy doesn't give a [ __ ] about Papa
John's family is shocker brownie pizza
is just a pepperoni and cheese oh yeah
this was I found this disturbing do you
see what they're trying to do here you
guys you see this why did it stop there
oh all of a sudden everybody's - Papa
Papa John's no no no really the entire
consciousness the names are gonna change
the really weird names - okay John's I
can get down with our cards Namah deeds
caressed ins what the hell oh geez
dougie I can get down with Papa Doug
nodded Eames what what are these names
Papa Daniels Papa Daniels our Papa no no
Daniel's but I'm not down to Papa
Daniel's branch that's already like
there's branch deli yeah hmm can true
but what I think what they're trying to
say is that everybody's the papa
totally yeah they're trying because Papa
John's they're trying to even take his
name out to get the name they're even
dropping the name Papa what did I do to
deserve this disrespect the fresh
ingredients the pie everything that you
stand for I bet it was my own hat
where's Bo I wanna see Papa bows bow is
too short they need their names with
long with more medicine complete the
Loco what did I you talk about the fresh
ingredients you talk about the family
how could you have for me
and so Shack my successor I say to this
you broke my heart
where's all the female names Maria yeah
no yeah a woman and makes you out cannot
be the head of pop I'm Papa's house
it's simply okay we need a bat Madonna
John yeah momma jump momma John's tough
gender-bending alright and finally I've
got you know that I've been obsessed
with bad Instagram food I've been
collecting data I've been gathering data
for you guys as pleasure and enjoyment
this video we're actually quite a field
this one shocked and appalled me it's
actually got 600,000 views and people
are into this now I am absolutely
appalled this is a abomination against
life somebody who I'm at stake man I
click prior to my steaks I cooked them
I'm a kind of an expert right now yeah
I'm a statesman now watch this
abomination against life first of all
how much butter is that you sick [ __ ]
[Applause]
boil this steak and butter now I was
like ok well maybe what is it gonna
grill it now is he gonna does he can put
on the grill and finish it off that's it
that's it that's it ready to serve oh my
god it looks white brain tissue yeah he
goes he goes experimental grilling
ribeye steak and butter thoughts my
thoughts are it looks awful no way that
is good that looks like I'm cook chicken
specially it's for if it and there's so
much butter
I can't get over it I got a tennis ball
some dog food looks better than that
that's a good point that's act now
wonderful tastes good though but you
know even if it tastes amazing I see you
eat with your eyes - oh my god it's
gotta look yellow listen to you let's go
I wonder if he grilled it if it out if
it wouldn't be good this this cracked me
up 600,000 views this is the Turkish
chef that I can't get enough of so here
he's preparing a bite of guest a muscle
watch how much lemon he puts on this
whoa dude that's way too much fun man he
squeezed the entire lemon on it juice
out of him that's got to taste so bad he
came to mustards my he squeezed so much
lemon juice on it I'm sure it just
tasted like pure lemon juice yeah I want
to watch that again
he's like a little lemon like I'm
freaking a whole glass of lemon juice
that is nasty bro
yeah Turkey in Turkey they got crazy
juicy lemons Brown man that guy I was
are not a hardy thumbs up here we go to
the lamb God he's a personal favorite of
mine he's making some meat hearts oh
this guy yeah this is the lamb classic
yeah this guy's a total legend do we
have a name
he's the me cos of lambda czn is the
name of his restaurant I love that no
look he slices and he doesn't look it's
like a hard flat and then he throws [ __ ]
like pretty aggressively I like that
he's got some meat patty a symbol for
symbol for that is kind of disease
you're gonna get if you eat it he's
actually a really talented chef he does
some cool [ __ ] come more chops and salt
bay that's for sure oh my god all day
the [ __ ] look at those both Oh little
beet heart I'm into it actually
one steak fourth I don't like this
constant labeling things porn food for
me I don't like it porn is porn steak
porn is someone putting their dick in a
steak that's it tasty food
I don't like porn you know but I don't
know if you knew that sheep the Sheep
God is super famous in turkey like here
I saw this video kind of puts it in
context for you he's cooking for like
the prime minister tons of famous people
come to his restaurant I mean take a
look at this guy like Michael Jackson
being torn over yeah
the women are glazing wow what the hell
yeah
he's huge five days ago - it's a new vid
the women are going crazy for him you
know I actually remember a long time ago
when we watch one of this guy's videos a
fan of ours emailed me who lives in
Turkey and tried to explain that he's
kind of a joke chef though like they
compared him to Guy Fieri he's like the
guys he's very much about the theatrics
right but I would eat it's got a
cornball cornball yeah he's a cornball
that's sure that's a good point
and salt Bay is the I don't know what
Saul pays I stands apart he's his own
beast yeah and finally just to send you
guys off for a beautiful peaceful I D
like weekend I've got young thug learns
that dogs have periods this crack now is
mine just got blown looking around for a
doll crazy crazy he's bought my bar yeah
I love it
traumatized by that well there you have
it guys top of the mother goddamn week
or whatever yo this is fantastic
we've done it all we've said it all
there it is
next week we have mr. beast in an
episode we pre-recorded while he was
here he was here recently last week
we're just gonna upload it on Friday
won't be we so we won't have a live show
but the absol will be going up at the
usual time being uploaded fun episode
great guy really interests
dude and the slow mo guys that we ended
up not working the schedule that was
supposed to be today but uh there were
scheduling issues that happens yeah and
then the following week we have Emma
Chamberlain right no and Gus Johnson
that's great that's terrific that's I'm
looking forward to that mm-hmm we got
people comment funny ass dude yeah I'm
really sweet into funny guy so don't
forget to turn up gets a little extra
extra extra extra you Dan how are you
doing how you been tell me about you I'm
good I've been good
it's it's been a crazy week with all
these stories been tracking them closely
and and then in the tweet it's like it
feels like a whole lifetime happened
this week yeah it's true and then there
was the no collusion which what I didn't
talk about it because I don't want to
get too deep and although you know that
was exhausting too yep for sure I mean
I'm just all this stuff is just have a
naughty thing I mean this guy psycho man
I'm just I feel vindicated I was saying
that guys just come back from the
beginning so I need to stop listening to
the news man like just altogether
because you get so invested in these
stories and then almost always they
amount to nothing and you're like why is
that that these always amount to nothing
I mean it's truly the media is just
hyping all the [ __ ] up for ratings yeah
and and you get invested you know
becomes the soap draw like a soap opera
you know and then people so I don't know
I'm yeah this new cycle has been very
exhausting for me
Ian hello yeah yeah tell me about
yourself I'm doing good feeling good
how's Kanye doing how's Kanye been he's
chilling I'm waiting for him to come
back I miss him so so much
what do you mean come back he's been off
the radar head to the news oh I mean
yeah yeah and I want to give it a little
I want that album I'm waiting oh thou
sure okay good and Zach everything's
good for you everything's getting your
well doing well I'm on a spring break
right now going down a can't count or
anything easier yeah I'm on I like to
work you like to work I do saddest thing
I've ever heard mmm our Kelly gets to
work and kept people touch his [ __ ]
mm-hmm that's a gig
that's a gig right there all right well
uh lots of excitement but in the back I
think everyone's ready to go
big party I'm ready to go play that
secure oh oh yeah we can have you you
have you played it yet Dan and almost a
couple hours it's hard as [ __ ] I can't I
love those games but I feel like it will
cause me stress it will stress me out
yeah I've played all the Dark Souls
games and blood-borne beat'em all
thought I was like good at those games
at this point and this [ __ ] has snapped
me back to reality he's destroying me
I see people debating if it's the
easiest or the hardest I think they
designed it to kind of [ __ ] with you if
you're used to all of their other games
mmm like they intentionally like all the
timing is like exactly you know when you
would dodge in one of those other games
is just is when you'll get [ __ ] up
whole game is like trolling me sayers in
big trouble she's obsessed with that
[ __ ] right yeah yeah I've been talking
to her she's also getting her ass kicked
I mean everybody I've talked to you this
plane it's it's hard I've thought about
picking it up but I think I just I'm too
I need I swear to god these games
stressed me out like Dark Souls it
upsets me one of my favorite all-time
honestly I must like it way up there I
try to play Tetris and it stresses me ya
know and that might be a sign that we
may be still doing the Tetris Royale
yeah you down with that I am I get first
place
No did you oh I made it to sixth place
to second place seconds good that's
really good but I mean I can't get
better like what about that first place
you know you can go get that a playa la
get there too
alright guys well uh whatever you're
doing this weekend I hope you're having
fun and taking it easy and relaxing
don't take everything in the news to
date seriously because it's all just a
bunch of be flippin Frick frack and
Hecht stir you up glue you to the [ __ ]
tube so entertain yourself take it easy
relax chances are if something's
bothering you you're not gonna be able
to fix it anyway
I mean truthfully so just let it go you
know take it easy man enjoy the little
time we have here on this earth because
uh when you die nothing happens that's
my opinion
hopefully I'm wrong I'd love to be wrong
well one thing's for certain you can
turn on the Xbox and play some video
games and have a good ass time so you
should because it's the weekend there
you go so we'll see you guys next week
and we have a new video that we're
working hard on that's coming out soon
that I'm very excited about I hope that
it turns out good me too
and wish you all the best we love you we
appreciate you oh you go to h3 shop com
h3 h3 shop a comment please buy
everything we're just getting rid of it
we're about free basically it is free
alright guys thanks y'all and have a
great weekend thanks for watching
[Music]
you